okay they're off the cheese
hold on one second
go ahead
all right copy that
um I where is four
yes they came between
all right copy that
foreign
copy that as well
uh backwards
hold on one second okay copy that okay
I'm sorry say that again Ryan or Randy
okay
you're almost perfect again
you really have a handle on where this
is so you're nailing it you're almost
perfect yeah you're there
all right
okay it is 56 now two minutes to the
open and
you're still good maybe a little back
and a little South
all right
yeah you have a really good handle on
where this is which is weird
um suitably impressed
you're like don't be I'm miserable
back slightly
I mean honestly I'm nitpicking at this
point it wouldn't matter we have it
okay a little bit South because I'm
gonna go into gimbal
and just a little bit more back
all right I think you're in a good spot
if anything back slightly
but yeah no you're solid now you're
solid solid solid perfect perfect
perfect
I just have to convince the camera not
to go in to give him a lock oh and it is
South a little bit
fudge oh
I'm I'm trying to save it South slightly
okay that'll do it
that's perfect
South a little bit I'm going into gimbal
all right oh damn it
ER
I I don't know yet I'm trying
yep
okay copy that
all right they're doing NJ and then us
yeah that's the spot there it doesn't
want to go into gimbal anymore so I
don't know why it's happier here
what up a mess huh
really
Jesus
so much for you could do this all day
you're like I'd like to take it back
I get it
that's her problem
all right do what you need to do
we're a little too far south now
yeah I don't know if it's making a
difference if that's why it's angry
yeah she sounds happy again
why am I losing ifb
I don't need this right now
okay what this is I'm trying to find ifb
hold on
uh to the right
and slightly back
and that's perfect no more North
here we go
yeah and if a picture is worth a
thousand words this picture might be
worth a million what we have been seeing
from overhead this is the Ann Street
side of the parking garage and what
we've seen is for the first time we've
seen people inside that demolition Zone
and heavy equipment literally plucked
one of the cars off of what was once the
roof of this building but when you look
at the roof and the cars you have them
facing literally in every which
direction some plummeting downward some
on their sides and some completely
overturned you see this one literally
straddling a massive Gap in what was
solid concrete at one point and what we
really want to show you is from the
front of the garage all the way to the
back you can see that crack went down
the entirety of that garage and this one
card all depended on where you parked
right this one car got caught right in
that collapse but right next to it you
see the crack forming in the concrete so
anyone parked to the left side those
cars are okay not that it's going to
matter because they're going to figure
out how to get these cars off and as NJ
mentioned this is going to be a
meticulous demolition because every time
they move a car a piece of concrete also
moves so it's a matter of doing a
controlled deduction to keep people safe
here and the buildings on either side
safe the dep is on hand as well to check
for asbestos in the air so far
everything has been under normal limits
reporting live over Lower Manhattan
Shannon Stone Channel 7 Eyewitness News
thank you okay do you want a circle do
you want to give yourself some breathing
room here
oh I don't know that's a good question
where are we fuel wise
hold on
ah
he's so loud okay
all right copy that
okay he's giving us a break anyway
whether we want it or not 29th and
Madison
does that make you happy
okay I did not hear your stuff because
he was so loud
yeah but what is what are we on fuel
400 so that's 15 30 minutes okay
all right
I'm like we got this
29th and Madison so Empire basically
that we're just waiting for the handoff
32nd and fifth so two blocks south of
Empire
three zero or three two
I thought he said three two but now I
think
okay now it's 3-0 in Madison somewhere
southeast of Empire
all right copy that
okay that is FM okay no this isn't the
wrong thing